[Music]  the last royal coronation ceremony was  in 1954 king mahabharata hong kong's  father Brahma denied his majesty king  bumi wanna do today  meaning that some ties have never seen a  coronation ceremony before in their  lives during and after the coronation  ties are encouraged to don yellow in  support of the king yellow represents  monday which is the day that king  mahabharata envoy was born  it is also why it's common to see yellow  during events associated with the royal  family  king rama the tenth technically already  ascended to the throne in December 2016  following the death of his father  however the royal coronation is the  final act there has been a total of  eleven coronation so far in devata-  period  [Music]